crazy complete different question for
you here
but do you think the washington redskins
being forced to change their names was
the right move
so that one's tricky too so because now
you have that name that's
over the top offensive there is no other
meaning for
uh that word other than to be derisive
right then you've got the indians and
you say well their mascots terrible but
the name itself is not necessarily
offensive then you got the chiefs a
perfectly acceptable name there's
nothing wrong with this seminoles is
actually
an ode to the particular tribe in the
area that's actually good it's almost
complementary so in the case of
washington it had no other meaning at
all it was obviously derisive uh and
there so i would say yes change it in
that case so changing it to commanders
whatever it is
i don't know i have to ask you guys
no clue so let me ask you this so
to to an armenian the young turks may be
offensive would you change your name
yeah so young turks means young rebels
that's the colloquial use in the english
language you could actually look it up
in the dictionary and for us it was
young progressives challenging the
established system i mean that is a
textbook definition of what we are quite
literally but i get that it is offensive
to armenian people i get that and so
uh and i and i feel terrible about that
especially because i was wrong about the
armenian genocide so when you talked
about that yes respect for the fact that
you did that yeah i think anna asked you
the question and you addressed it yeah
yeah and so i say her name right anna
right yeah yeah uh so when i was growing
up i grew up with honestly turkish
propaganda right and so we all get
propaganda you guys talk about the
education system you know what is it
telling people yeah i remember we they
taught this absurd thing that i didn't
realize i was absurd because i was kid
right they said turks had never lost the
war except world war one now world war
one was a little hard to deny right so
but i believe that and i remember as a
grown up i remember reading about how
the ottomans had lost the battle and i
was like no no the turks never
oh my god i can't believe i believed
that all these years because they
implanted it in my head right and of
course that's not true the church has
lost tons of battles and wars right and
one of the things that was taught was
that the genocide didn't happen well of
course it happened serbanita is
considered a genocide and 8 000 people
died there right in the armenian
genocide
way more than that a lot more than that
died and they didn't target norwegians
they targeted armenians so was it based
on uh
that ethnicity race clearly it was and
and they were targeted so
uh i
as i've changed a lot of positions based
on facts i changed my position on that
based on facts and i feel terrible that
i had that earlier position and i've
been super clear about it yeah the fact
that you change it that's respect to you
for doing that you know it was one and a
half million armenians give or take two
to three hundred thousand assyrians i
want to say five hundred thousand greeks
when you you read about the genocide
it's a lot of armenians but there's also
syrians and greeks part of that as well
but my my response back to your first
question would be not my first question
would be i don't think redskins need to
change their name just like you don't
need to change your name if your name is
young turks and you offend a guy like me
who's armenian and assyrian and i don't
like it i don't have to like it but i
don't have to say let's make sure he
changes his name it's your name and by
the way there is an armenian community
that's you know you look at the american
indian community what is the size of
that what is the armenian size community
what is the assyrian community what is a
greek community some people say dude
that's offensive i get what you're
saying it's a young progressive but it's
a young turks so i think
the the part where sometimes you know we
play this change your name i'm offended
i'm this i'm that i am offended but i
don't expect you to change it i expect
you to stay with the name that you
created that's the whole thing i'm
thinking about with the redskins thing
anyways that was one thing i friend of
mine brought it up i said let me talk to
jenk about it and see what it is if you
enjoyed this short clip click over here
to watch another short clip and if you
want to watch the entire episode the
entire podcast click here
[Music]
you